[Musique]
en face ils ont inventé et bonne touche
et quand un tison est de retour à son
école primaire
après avoir fait des stages dans
différents milieux de travail
le jeune autiste de 22 ans a trouvé ça
boit copains c'est vrai beaucoup aidés
nous sommes un peu réconforté c'est plus
que quelqu'un qui nous est son ami on
joue souvent avec lui le prend quand
même
ouais un grand ami un grand frère il
nous est commun de petits problèmes
il aime faire le théâtre avec lui la
science il s'investit beaucoup ont tant
avec les élèves avec les employés c'est
on aime beaucoup campait la secrétaire
de l'école se souvient très bien de
quentin et d'attachant donc mais nous
c'est sûr qu'elle est classé s on les
voit plus souvent les voit évoluer la
fusion primaire ici il était resté dans
une classe je sais pas comment on
appelle les classes ont ils à des
autistes
si je dirais qu'aujourd'hui refuge était
avant et est comparé ya maintenant y
avoir une grande différence de tsa qui
sont ici il faut souvent genre des
crises car ils sont pas contents quand
c'est ça mais ça c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont méchants à 12 juste parce que jari
savent pas comment l'exprimer autrement
outre son travail au service de garde
quentin a développé un lien particulier
avec une classe de 4e année où il passe
ses lundi après midi
quant à quentin rendant l'atlas c'est
comme s'il faisait partie du groupe
c'est un homme qui est extrêmement
attachant c'est un homme qui va
développer des relations avec les autres
et toujours dans le bien toujours dans
le bon sens
parmi les personnes qui ont fait la
route avec quentin une enseignante du
sas le secondaire adapté à ta situation
ça c'est vraiment de l'inclusion c'est
pas de l'intégration en emploi c'est
vraiment de l'inclusion par moi je
trouve ça vraiment fabuleux parce que
quand on a commencé à couler même pas
dire il a fait plusieurs stages en
restauration dans des commerces puis
auprès des enfants en service de garde
je n'ai vu comme vraiment s'intéresser à
chacun des élèves à regarder quand on
allait moins bien et qui a développé des
interventions il ya des gens qui font
des cours qui sont et qui n'ont pas
cette sensibilité que quand on développe
et fait que c'est un intervenant
magnifique moi je suis pas du tout
étonnée trail dans une école parce que
quentin là il ya commencé à être heureux
cet enfant l'oeil épanouie cattier
rentrée à l'école
une réussite qui va bien au-delà de ce
que sa famille pouvait espérer pour ce
petit garçon particulier
diagnostic comme ça on peut retrousser
nos manches et puis aller chercher tout
ce qu'il faut pour outiller notre enfant
on a beaucoup de soutien aux six ans
donc on a eu
noyau familial cr et sa soeur juliette
c'est vraiment la meilleure éducatrice
qui eût j'ai appris ce qu'était
l'autisme en essayant de décrire mon
frère aux autres je me l'expliquer comme
ça puis je me donnais peut-être là la
mission est un peu cheap de de
l'expliquer aux gens pour ça s'est
toujours bien passé très populaire dans
tout le quartier
mais oui je trouve ça change ça l'fun
puis pour lui aussi ça a dû être comme
un petit retour au tour des enfants de
façon ils vont redonner ce qu'on lui a
donné un peu maintenant il est là sommes
un peu de tout les enseignants qui a
rencontré les éducateurs qui a rencontré
des collections compris en lui les les
prof d'arts dramatiques comme un exemple
pourrait en fait en étant lorsque je
suis maintenant être libye même y être
utile encore l'an prochain
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal
[Musique]